half of sales at least for a phone sales
person or zoom sales person is talking
and the other half is listening and so
for half of the the 60 minutes in the
morning they spend reading the script
out loud with the correct tonality and
they read it three times through without
messing up if they mess up they go to
the top of it the second half they go
through a call from the day before from
one of the guys and they either pick
about what they did well or they didn't
do well where they missed something or a
tonality drop and they didn't attack her
there was a belief pattern that they
didn't confront then blew up in the
clothes like things like that we have
three loops that we practice one is
about trusting me one is about trusting
the product and the other about trusting
the company and so based on the option
they have we always agree with them be
like totally understand where you're
coming from and then we ignore it and
loop all the way back around and ask
again right and so it's really in theory
you could have infinite loops but
usually constrained by time